BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right,
welcome everyone.
My name is Bruno Oliveira.
And I work with Android
Developer Relations.
And we're going to talk about
In-App Billing Version 3.
So it's pretty cool.
In-App Billing is actually
a pretty cool thing.
And every time we talk to
someone about In-App Billing,
we sort of expect them
to go like this.
And but sometimes, in the
previous versions of the API,
if you've worked with In-App
Billing V2, they
sometimes go like that.
And we really don't understand
why that happens.
Because if they're all in
a billing spree, it's in
command, right?
So just to go back in
time a little bit,
things used to be--
well, things were
actually pretty
straightforward back then.
In V2, you would just have
to make a purchase,
kind of like that.
And then that's done, right?
Easy.
Well, actually, I'm just
oversimplifying a little bit.
You actually had to have code
to handle the purchase date
changes, like that.
Still, it's not that
much code.
But then you have that case
where the app could be
sleeping when you got
that message.
So you also had to have a
broadcast receiver to make
sure that that didn't happen,
so just broadcast receiver.
Still not complicated, right?
And then, of course, the
broadcast receiver couldn't
really run for very long because
it would get killed by
the system.
So it's probably good
practice [INAUDIBLE]
a service, like pretty simple
and straightforward service,
to handle that broadcast
receiver.
And of course, then since you
can't credit for the purchases
all the time because it's an
expensive API call, you
probably need to persist at
using a database of some sort.
But that's OK.
Everyone loves databases.
It's SQL.
And well, why does it really
gets so complicated?
And even this is an
oversimplification because you
have to encrypt the database.
Make sure that the users
don't tamper with it.
So why does it get so
complicated with In-App
Billing in the previous
versions?
Well, let's start with
a simple case.
So the user-- that's my
drawing of a user.
Again, it's probably fortunate
that I write code better than
I draw pictures.
But then the user
buys something.
And that gets delivered
to the app.
No problem there, right?
So standard.
But what happens if the
application is not there to
receive the package, because
applications on Android
sometimes have other
stuff to do?
So sometimes apps go to
sleep on Android.
They take naps.
So what if the app
is sleeping?
Then a different component has
to pick up the package.
And then that component has to
take care of delivering the
item to the application when
it finally wakes up.
And that's when the problems
might happen because that
component right there could end
up losing your package.
As you can see from this diagram
in V2, the developer
had to write many components
that had to work together to
ensure that the user's
purchase went
to the right place.
And of course, it can get
a little complicated.
In comparison, this is what
the V3 diagram looks like.
Actually, let me use a little
bit more of the slide.
No, let's make it
a full slide.
The diagram for V3 has
seven subcomponents.
We're going to spend the next
several minutes discussing
each component and subcomponent
in detail.
Actually, just kidding.
This is the actual diagram.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
in V3, apart from glass boxes,
is that API calls are now
synchronous.
This means that your application
gets a response
right away.
So if I want to-- and it's also
much more straightforward
to think about too.
So if I want to buy something
like 50 gold coins, all I have
to do is make a request that
looks like buy 50 gold coins.
Then if Google Play thinks a
purchase is OK, it's going to
return something that's pretty
intuitive, like say OK.
And you get that response
right away.
If you worked with V2 before,
you're probably going to
remember that our advice, the
advice we gave every time is
that listing items, which we
call restoring purchases, was
a very, very expensive
operation.
Nobody could afford to do that
a whole bunch of times.
So you couldn't just get away
with calling it every single
time the app launched.
You had to somehow keep a
client-side storage to know
which items either owns.
So that's no longer the case
because in V3, Google Play
implements a client-side cache
and takes care of keeping that
cache in sync with the server.
So whenever you make your query
to the API, you're going
to hit that client-side cache
instead of incurring that cost
of a network round trip.
So you can call it as many
times as you want.
So listing the user's items has
actually become a pretty
cheap operation.
And you can do that as
often as you need.
For example, you can do that
every time the application
starts, which we figure is a
pretty natural place where you
might want to ask yourself, what
items does this user own?
All right, so I probably sound
like I'm trying to sell you
something, right?
So if you're a developer, I
mean, if you're in this room,
you've probably grown a healthy
mistrust over the
years of people who stand on a
stage like me and then don't
show you any actual code.
So let's stop with the sales
and talk about something
that's entirely different.
Let's talk about
selling stuff.
So before you can make V3 API
calls, you have to check that
it's actually supported.
You can do that by calling the
isBillingSupported API call.
The good news is that In-App
Billing is actually supported
on a whole variety of devices,
so running Froyo and above and
a recent version of
the Play Store.
And there was actually more than
90% on the day that we
launched, which was back
a few months ago.
And right now, of course,
there's much more than that.
So you don't have to be too
worried about that.
Now how do you go ahead and get
a list of the items that
the user owns?
Well, we just call the
getPurchases API call.
And remember that this call is
actually pretty cheap on V3.
Notice also that you
get the results
right away right there.
So there's no funny call backs
or state management, no funny
business you have to implement
to get the result right away.
All right, so now this
is very important.
It's that single moment your
application has been waiting
for ever since the
user launched it.
It's that profound moment in
modern technology that's very
hard to explain to older
generations, where the user
actually realizes that the
virtual item or service that
you're offering them is so
valuable and they like it so
much that they are actually
willing to give you
real money for it.
That's awesome, right?
So it's at that singular moment
you have something
that's really, really, really,
really very valuable.
And I'm not talking
about those $0.99
that you just made.
What you have on that moment
is the user's trust.
So they give you their money.
And they expect to get
something in return.
And nothing is more valuable to
an application than that.
So what happens if at that
critical moment you take the
user's money and then
you lose a purchase?
That's going to be a very
bad user experience.
So again, they've paid for
something and didn't get it.
The least you can expect after
that is a pretty bad review.
And of course, if you're
unlucky, it may be very, very
much worse than that, as this
very reliable data that I in
no way made up clearly
demonstrates.
So you don't want the user to
lose their purchase ever,
which is why one of the central
points in V3 was to
make it easier to
do exactly that.
So it was to make it easier
not to lose purchases.
One of the ways we do that is
by making all items managed,
which means that Google Play
keeps track of the ownership
of those items for you.
So going back to code, how do
you write this reliable
purchase flow?
First of all, you launch
the purchase screen.
And that can be done by
calling getBuyIntent.
So that's going to get to a
ready-to-use intent that you
can then fire, and that's
going to bring you the
purchase screen.
And what does that look like?
So I have a game called
Nostalgic Racer.
And then I have 1,000 points,
1,000 nostalgic points, if you
will, and that the user
can purchase.
So notice that this dialogue is
pretty much it's simple and
to the point.
And the user doesn't lose
context, because it's overlaid
on top of the game.
This is an improvement we
launched a few months ago.
So and there's really only
one button in that UI.
And it really says, click me.
Right?
And so there's no context
lost, no confusion.
And the result of the dialogue
when the user clicks Buy is
that you're going to
get the results
through an activity result.
So what do you do
at the point?
Well, at that point, you have
the purchase result.
So you have the response code.
You have the purchase data and
the purchase signature.
Everything is right there.
So when I say purchase data,
what I mean is just this J as
an object that looks
kind of like that.
So you have the order ID.
You have the package name
that bought the product.
You have the product ID, which
is also known as your SKU.
You have the purchase time,
the purchase date, the
developer payload.
That's something very important
that we're going to
talk about next.
And you have the purchase
token, which is a long,
alphanumeric string
that identifies
that particular purchase.
So that's pretty much all
there is for a simple
application.
So on startup, you call
getPurchases to figure out
what the user owns.
And then when the user wants
to purchase something, you
call getBuyIntent.
That gives you a ready-to-use
intent that you can fire.
When you fire that intent, you
get the purchase flow.
And then onActivityResult,
you handle that purchase.
Notice that it's actually
pretty hard to lose a
purchase that way.
You would actually have to
make an effort to lose a
purchase this way, because
even if the unthinkable
happens and, say, your
application has a bug, what
happens, if your application
crashes right after the
purchase and never gets the
onActivityResult, that's not a
problem because then the next
time the user is going to
start the app, you're going
to call getPurchases.
And you're going to realize
that the item's there.
So the user has not
lost the purchase.
All right, so phones are
funny things, actually.
So they have a tendency to
fall into all sorts of
liquids, like from sea
to margaritas.
So they have a tendency.
They have an attraction
to liquids that
science doesn't explain.
What also happens is that
phones tend to fall.
But as you know, contrary to
popular belief, falling
doesn't really do anything
to a phone.
The problem is when the phone
collides with something
massive, like say a planet.
So the planet tends to
win in that case.
But don't worry.
That's OK, because the beauty of
managed In-App purchases is
that they're like diamonds.
They're forever.
So even if the user deletes the
app or even if they switch
to a different device, it's OK
because the purchase is still
going to be there.
And they haven't lost it.
So this is good for things
that the user should only
purchase once, like for
instance, a premium upgrade--
even if the user switches
phones, you don't want them to
lose that--
an ad-free upgrade, special
items that the user can never
lose, or even level packs,
content, and
so on and so forth.
So for all that, it's this
purchase once and use
everywhere is a pretty
good approach.
But sometimes, of course,
you don't want a
purchase to be forever.
You want to implement things
like consumable items, like
health potions and whatnot, gold
coins that are put into
the player's wallet and then
they go away, things that
expires like season passes.
And then you have to, of course,
to purchases that are
not permanent.
And this is what unmanaged
item was used for in V2.
But of course, there are no
unmanaged items in V3.
So how do you do that?
Well, this is why we have the
consumption APIs on V3.
So to understand how this works,
so somewhere in Google
Play-- so there's a building
where Google Play works.
And in the basement of that
building, every single user at
Google has a box.
And inside that box, with
my name on it, are
all my virtual items.
I know.
I've been there.
I've seen that box.
When I buy a cool item, what
happens is that somebody goes
in there and puts the cool item
inside the box that has
my name on it.
And from that point on, I know
I own the cool item.
When I subsequently ask, what
items does Bruno own, through
an API call, it returns well,
Bruno owns a cool item.
Then what happens when I tell
the API to consume cool item?
What happens is that
the item goes up in
flames, just like that.
And then, if I ask what items
does Bruno own, I don't own
anything at all.
So consumption is the opposite
of a purchase.
When you consume, the
item goes away.
As far as code goes, this is
how you consume an item.
We would just call the
consumePurchase on the API.
And then you give it
the purchase token
associated with that item.
Remember that the purchase token
is the same one that you
got when you got the
getPurchases call.
And then that's the purchase
token field on that JSON.
And then, well, then
you call that.
And the item's going
to be consumed.
Now, there is one decision that
you're going to have to
make, which is when to
consume something.
So it's up to you how to
decide how to use the
consumption API.
The contract is that
when you consume
something, it goes away.
So we're going to talk about two
of the most used methods
when you're using the
consumption API.
First of all, maybe you want to
consume the item when it's
actually used because that's, by
far, the most intuitive way
to consume an item, right?
Then you don't need to manage
the items yourself.
Now the second approach, which
is pretty popular, is to
consume it immediately
upon purchase.
In that case, your
app takes care of
managing the user's inventory.
So you might call that inventory
a wallet, a purse, a
bag, account, or
any other name.
But you will manage the user's
inventory in that case.
So to explain method
one quickly--
so let's give an example.
So again, that's me.
It's a stick figure
character of me,
anyway, somewhat slimmer.
And those are the items that
I own in Google Play.
So right now, it's an
empty box, right?
Now, as we all know, the world
out there is a pretty
dangerous place, especially for
stick figure characters
like myself.
So I decided before I go out
into the world, I'm going to
buy a health potion.
So I buy a health potion.
And when I do that, it appears
in my inventory.
Also like everybody else, I walk
around with a head point
bar on top of my head
that tells me what
my life points are.
So now I have a potion
that I bought.
And it's on my box
in Google Play.
And I own that potion.
Now I go out, and I venture into
the wild lands of bugs.
And then I battle bugs,
and I write code.
Pretty soon I realize
that I'm starting to
get low on life points.
And then I decide to
consume the potion.
That's when your application
would call the consumption API
to make that potion disappear
and then restore my life point
bar back to what
it was before.
So this is consumption
upon usage.
Now, that's a perfectly good
method, except that it has one
fundamental limitation.
And that has to do with
how Google Play
thinks about numbers.
So Google Play, at least as far
as In-App purchases are
concerned, only really
knows two numbers.
And they are 0 and 1.
So if the world out there is
really, really dangerous, and
I think I'm going to need more
than one healing potion out
there to battle bugs,
then I'm going to
want to buy two potions.
But what happens if I try
to buy a potion when I
already have one?
So Google Play is going to look
at me, and it's going to
see that I have a potion
right there.
And it's going to say,
that makes no sense.
You already have a potion.
Why are you trying to
buy a second one?
So clearly, this approach
doesn't work if you want to
have more than one item of each
kind, which is why method
two might come in handy, which
is consuming upon purchase.
In this case, your application
is actually responsible for
managing the user's inventory.
So notice my excellent
[INAUDIBLE] of a plastic bag
right there, which is my
client-side inventory or
service-side.
Either way, it's managed
by my application.
So I buy a potion.
And now the potion exists in
my Google Play inventory.
Then what I do is, regardless
of when the user is going to
consume this, I consume
the potion right
away through the API.
And I credit that to my
in-game inventory.
And then if the user buys a
second one, that's no problem
because Google Play doesn't know
about a potion anymore.
So I can buy a second potion and
consume it right away and
credit it to my bag.
So now I have two potions
in my inventory.
If you're using method two, it's
very important not only
to consume upon purchase,
but also upon startup.
And then on startup, you check
if there any outstanding items
that you should be consumed.
This is going to be necessary,
for example, if your
application crashed before
it consumed the item.
So suppose the user
made the purchase.
The purchase went through.
But then your application
crashed.
Then when your application
recovers and starts again,
you're going to make sure that
on startup you check if
there's any item in the user's
inventory that should have
been consumed, but was not.
So in our example, what I'm
going to do on startup is call
getPurchases.
And if I realize that I own a
potion that should have been
consumed, I'm going to consume
it right away and then put it
into the player's inventory.
You don't even have to notify
the player that you're
actually doing that.
You can do that in
the background.
So summarizing what we have so
far-- on startup, you would
call getPurchases.
Then if I notice that there is
a potion there that should
have been consumed before,
I consume it.
When the user wants to make a
purchase, I call getBuyIntent
and then launch that intent
to get the purchase flow.
And that's the window
that prompts
the user to buy something.
Then when I get the
onActivityResult call back,
what I do is I check if the
purchase was successful.
And then I consume the purchase
if the purchase was
successful.
And then when I get the consume
call back, I see if
the consume was successful.
If the consume was successful,
then I finally add the potion
to the inventory.
It's very important to wait for
the last part before you
actually credit the item to the
user's inventory because
what may happen is that--
remember that the Google Play
inventory is the same
for every device.
So it's per user and
not per device.
So if I own a potion on one
device, then I own a potion on
all devices.
So when you are going to consume
that potion, you
should make sure that you only
created the potion once.
So if you try to consume the
same potion from several
devices, only one of those
consumptions is going to succeed.
So that's guaranteed.
So this means you should only
credit the potion once it's
been successfully consumed.
All right?
So In-App Billing V3 also brings
a long-anticipated
feature that developers have
been really asking for a long
time, which is the ability to
query for a product's details
from code, like for instance,
title, description, and price.
So if you take a look at the
API, you're going to find this
method call, which is called
getSkuDetails.
It's actually pretty
straightforward.
You just specify the list of
SKUs that you want to get
information about.
And when you make that call,
the API returns the
information in a bundle.
And that bundle kind
of looks like this.
So it has your product's ID,
which is the SKU, the type,
whether it's in a product or a
subscription, the price, the
title, description, so
on and so forth.
One thing that's pretty nice
about this is that the price
is actually returned in a way
that's formatted according to
the user's locale.
So it's going to look right to
the user when you display it
on the screen.
However, one thing to be careful
about is that price is
only formatted for display
and not for parsing.
So don't try to use
that as a number.
Don't try to add two together.
This is just a number that's
formatted for display only.
And you can show
it to the user.
Now let's talk about
subscriptions.
So in V3, that's actually
pretty simple too.
If you have used V2, you'll
remember that there was a
whole bunch of messages and
call backs and broadcast
receivers that you had to write
to implement and to know
the status of a particular
subscription
at any given time.
And there were asynchronous
call backs
that you had to implement.
But in V3, it's much easier.
They are actually
just like items.
They're much simpler.
To check if substitutions are
supported, you can call
isBillingSupported API call.
So it's the same as before,
except you pass
subs instead of in-app.
And then that's going to
return whether or not
subscription are supported
on that device.
So it's important to
make that check.
Now launching the purchase flow
for a subscription is not
really very different from
launching the purchase flow
for a regular item.
So we just use getBuyIntent.
But except that instead of
saying in-app, you say subs.
And then you go past the item
type, and then get an intent.
You can launch the intent.
And that brings the purchase
window, just like did before.
One thing to be careful
about is that
subscriptions can't be consumed.
So you cannot use the
consumption API on a
subscription.
If the effect that you're trying
to accomplish is to
cancel a subscription, then
this is another way to do.
You're going to have to do that
through the server-side,
as we're going to see next.
All right, so remember how I
said that in V2 it's actually
pretty difficult to know
what's the state of a
subscription?
So in V3, it's actually pretty
easy because you just call
getPurchases.
When you call getPurchases
with the item type set to
subs, it's going to return all
the subscriptions that are
actually active right now.
What I mean by actually active
is that while subscriptions
are either in the active state
or in the trial state--
the trial state that the user
can have before buying the
subscription--
those are going to appear in
your getPurchases results.
Now once a subscription expires,
you're not going to
get any notification of that.
But then the next time you
call getPurchases--
which, remember, became a pretty
cheap call, so every
time your application starts,
you can call getPurchases.
So the very next time you call
getPurchases, what's going to
happen is that the expired
subscription is no longer
going to be there.
So it does not appear
on getPurchases.
So your whole logic can be, if
I see the subscription in
getPurchases, then I provide
the content.
If I don't see the subscription
in getPurchases,
then I don't provide
the content.
It's much easier logic than
trying to manage what's a
subscription state at
any given point.
So how about canceled
subscriptions?
Well, we do the right thing for
canceled subscriptions as
well, which is canceled
subscriptions are actually
going to appear in getPurchases
until the end of
the billing period that
the user has paid for.
So after that expires,
they cease to appear.
So you may see canceled
subscriptions in getPurchases.
And that may happen because
the user has paid for the
billing period, but they
have canceled it.
So on the next billing
period, that
subscription's going to expire.
So as far as the developer's
concerned, all they have to do
is check if it's in
getPurchases.
If it is, you deliver
the content.
If it's not, you
don't deliver.
Now remember that Google Play
actually now has a local cache
on the client, which means
that when a subscription
expires, it might actually
take some time for it to
disappear from getPurchases.
Usually that doesn't really
take more than
24 hours, of course.
So that cache is refreshed
every 24 hours at most.
So you might actually see a
subscription there that has
already expired.
But then, hopefully, that's
only going to
last 24 hours or so.
That's usually not a big deal.
All right?
So when you're making any API
calls, it's very important to
be careful about
the UI thread.
So the UI thread's something
that's very delicate.
Why?
Because if you block the UI
thread, your application is
going to stop responding,
of course.
And in the Android world, I
mean, actually in any mobile
application, that's not just
something that's frowned upon.
The system actually punishes
your app for that.
And the punishment, of course,
this is very, very friendly
dialogue box.
So if you don't want the users
to see this dialogue box,
because users just absolutely
love that dialogue box, then
you shouldn't ever block the
UI thread by calling
[INAUDIBLE] that take a
long time to return.
Particularly in the In-App
Billing API, the safe ones to
call are isBillingSupported
and getBuyIntent.
Those two you can call safely
from the UI thread because
they're returned right away.
Now the other three that we
talked about are not safe to
call from the UI thread because
they might actually
take a while to execute.
So if you're calling
getPurchases, consumePurchase,
getSkuDetails, remember that
they might actually take a
while to execute.
So you definitely do not want
to call them from the UI
thread in order not to
risk a application
not responding error.
So always call them from a
separate thread, async task,
whatever else.
But whatever you do, don't
block the UI thread while
waiting for that response.
If you download the sample
that's called Trivial Drive,
it implements that for you
because it has asynchronous
wrappers so that you can
actually call them from the UI
thread and get a call back
when they are done.
Now many developers
don't know this.
But there's actually a
server-side API that allows
you to check for
subscriptions.
The way it works is this API
allows you to take a
particular subscription and then
query whether or not it's
valid, when it's going to
expire, and whether or not
it's going to renew itself
automatically.
It also allows you to cancel an
existing subscription from
the server side.
So how do you go ahead and
specify a particular
subscription?
Well, remember the purchase data
on the client side when
you call getPurchases?
So one of the fields in that
is called purchaseToken.
So that identifies that
particular subscription for
that particular user.
So that's the string that you
need to use on the server side
to call that API.
So this is what I know of what
a sample API call looks like.
It's basically REST.
And I'm calling the state of
that particular subscription.
So I pass it to you.
Your package name goes there.
Your subscription ID, so this is
the SKU of the subscription
goes there.
And then that's the token that
you get from the client-side.
The response looks something
like this.
And it gives you when the
subscription started, when
it's going to expire, and then
whether or not it's going to
renew automatically.
If you want to know more about
this API, there's that URL
right there.
So there's the full
specification of that API.
It also allows you to cancel a
subscription from the server
side, which might be useful
for your application.
Now, next, let's talk about
a very important
topic, which is security.
Now security is important
because, believe it or not,
there are some shady characters
out there in the
interwebs who might
want to take your
stuff without paying.
I know, it's shocking.
And they are out there on
the web, on the loose.
So it's very important to
implement some measure of
security in applications.
So I don't really know what
the technical term is.
But I'm going to say they're
pirates, mostly because we
spent a really long time drawing
this character, and I
wanted to use it in
a presentation.
So actually, I think they're
called crackers.
But let's go with pirates.
So anyway, anytime you see
a purchase result in your
application, you should always
ask yourself if you should
trust the purchase or not.
Of course, a pirate's is going
to be-- pirates spend all day
being a pirate.
And their job is to convince you
that a particular purchase
is correct.
And of course, your job is to
detect that lie and see that
that purchase is a fake.
So how do you go ahead
and do that?
Well, depending on your
particular type of app and
market, piracy might
be a small problem,
might be a big problem.
That's going to depend
on your type of app.
But you should always think in
terms of risk model that takes
into account several variables,
such as the target
audience, the item's value, the
likelihood that somebody
would make a fake purchase, the
technical difficulty in
making a purchase.
And based on that, make a
decision on how much security
to implement.
Of course, in the best case
scenario, we implement all
possible security.
But then you might have to
balance that against
engineering time and
so on and so forth.
So it's important to be
conscious of that.
Of course, nobody can stop
piracy all together.
I would be lying to you if I
said that I had a method to
stop piracy.
But of course, you should always
make life hard for
piracy because that's fun.
So here's some of the defenses
that you can employ to make a
pirate's life hard.
First of all is use our
developer payload, and then
use signature verification,
and also server-side
validation.
We're going to give a quick
overview of each one of those.
So what's this developer
payload thing?
Well, developer payload
is really just a
fancy term for a tag.
So it's just a tag that
gets attached to
a particular purchase.
It's an arbitrary string.
Anytime you launch the purchase
flow, you can specify
what the string is.
It's just a string that gets
attached to the purchase.
And then every single time you
credit for that purchase and
you get that purchase, that
string's going to be there.
Now, of course, you can write
anything into it.
But of course, one of the most
useful applications of this is
to identify the owner of
a particular purchase.
Why do you want to identify
the owner of
a particular purchase?
Because then it makes it very
hard for somebody to take the
purchase data and then replay
it into s different device.
So again, that's me, the stick
figure, of course.
Like everyone else--
I mean, it's a scientific
fact.
It's been scientifically proven
that everyone, everyone
has an evil twin somewhere.
Now this is Onurb,
my evil twin.
He is not nearly as
honest as I am.
So last week, he picked up my
device and did a database dump
of the items that I had and
then replayed them on his
device, hoping to get some
of my items for free.
So of course, if your
application is using developer
payload, this is what's
going to happen.
So Onurb, my evil twin, is
going to run your app.
And then you're going to check
what items does Onurb own.
And you're going to
see this purchase.
Do you see anything suspicious
at all about this purchase?
Well, of course.
The developer payload says
it belongs to Bruno.
But it's Onurb that's
running the app.
Of course, on a real
application, you would not use
first names because some people
have evil twins that
have the same first name.
So you would not use names, but
some unique ID, like for
instance, the Google+ ID
or something like that.
Also it's actually pretty hard
to fake that signature,
because every purchase comes
signed from the server.
So it's not actually trivial
just to change that purchase.
So speaking about signature
verification, well, what is
this thing about signature
verification?
Well, every application has a
public key and a private key.
The private key never
leaves Google.
So the private key is only
known to Google.
And you know the public key
for your application.
What this means is that whenever
somebody signs
something with your private key
and that, of course, by
definition, has to be Google
because we are the only ones
that have the private key, then
you can use the public
key for your app to verify
that signature to know
that we signed it.
So Google Play signs every
single purchase that goes
through Google Play gets signed
with your application's
private key, which means that,
when you get a purchase on
your application, you should use
your application's public
key to check that the
signature matches.
If it does not, it's a fake.
It's not actually difficult
to implement signature
verification.
But if you don't want to
implement that, that's
actually available
in our sample.
So Trivial Drive has a helper
class that does all that
signature verification
for you.
So you don't even have
to implement that.
Now, all right, even though--
client-side signature
verification is
pretty cool, right?
But don't think that client-side
security alone is
going to be enough
for your app.
That would be a mistake because
regardless of how
difficult you make things,
the reality is that
phones can be hacked.
So you should definitely
secure the
server side as well.
So when we say server-side
verification, what we mean is
that on the server side, you
should check the signature
again just to make sure that
the client does not
compromise.
And then one cool thing you can
do on the server, which
you can't do on the client, is
that you can check the order
number because the server is
seeing every single purchase
that comes from every
single person.
So every purchase comes
with an order number.
And they should be unique.
So if you ever see a second
purchase with the same number
as a purchase that you've
already provisioned before,
then you know that that second
purchase is a fake.
So you should always check the
order number and dedup it.
Also, if you're doing this,
make sure to secure the
handshake because I've seen
pretty sad stories of
developers that spent countless
man hours devising
this perfect server-side
security system.
And then their handshake was
like a boolean call.
It was like a REST call that
returned to boolean, saying
true, you are validated
or not.
And then, of course, that can be
easily circumvented with a
man in the middle attack.
So make sure that the handshake
is secure if you're
going through the trouble of
implementing a server-side
security like that.
Also make sure that the
handshake between the server
and the client is secure and
not triggered to break.
Now to give a summary of the
security methods that we
talked about.
Of course, you are free
not to do anything.
If you don't do anything, then
you're pretty much vulnerable
to any attack.
Maybe for your application
that's not going to matter.
But then you should probably
just add at least client-side
security because if you at
least add client-side
signature verification, that's
actually very easy to do
because it's implemented
for you.
It's available in the sample.
It's just a matter of copying
and pasting that.
So if you add client-side
signature verification, you're
going to be protected against
man in the middle attacks.
So you're going to be protected
against everyone's
evil twin who tries to
replay a purchase
on a different device.
Now if you want to go the extra
mile and then add a
unique developer payload, of
course, you are also protected
against the more elaborate
forms of purchase replay.
And next, if you want to be
really secure, you should, of
course, implement server-side
signature verification.
The server-side signature
verification's going to
protect you even in the case
that the client's phone is
hacked, and then the framework
has been compromised.
So definitely think about
implementing server-side security.
Well, so overall, it's important
to approach the
problem of piracy in a
very rational way.
And that means don't panic and
implement methods that are
known to be effective.
So at least as far as the In-App
Billing platform's
concerned, these are the three
that we talked about.
And definitely they are the ones
that you should have in
mind because they're very easy
to implement-- so developer
payload that identifies the user
of course, then signature
verification, and also doing
server-side validation.
And the last topic for today,
it's something that developers
have been asking us
for a long time.
So I'm actually glad
that this launched.
So and this is the In-App
Billing sandbox.
So what's the sandbox thing?
Well, if you remember how things
used to be, when you
wanted to test to make sure
that your In-App Billing
implementation was working
right, you essentially had two
choices when testing
In-App purchase.
You could just use the test
SKUs, the purchased and
canceled SKUs, which are, of
course, fake product codes.
And they always return a
given purchase result.
So you could, of course,
use that.
And those are, of course,
mock products with a
mock purchase flow.
They don't actually go
through the server.
And then they get
a mock result.
Of course, if you were not
satisfied with that and, of
course, if you wanted to do
something that's closer to
production, you could
use that.
You could use a test account.
And of course, if you list
somebody as a test account,
the only privilege they used
to have is that they could
make purchases from
an application
that was not yet published.
But you had to use real money,
had to use a real credit card,
has to use a real
purchase flow.
And then you would actually
get charged for that.
Of course, you could revert the
charge by refunding it.
But then maybe the bank's not
going to be happy and so on
and so forth.
But it's just very
complicated.
So with In-App Billing sandbox,
you can now test
purchases with the real
products, using the actual
real purchase flow, with
a real credit card.
So everything is as real as
possible, except that that
last step, when your credit card
is about to be charged,
that doesn't happen.
So that's the only
part that's mock.
But that's the only part that
doesn't happen is you don't
get charged.
But otherwise, the whole
flow is actually real.
So how do you go ahead
and set this up?
To enable that, you simply add
some test account to the list
of test accounts in the
publisher's site.
So this is the Android
publisher site.
You go to Account Details.
Then you add a list of test
accounts over there, so some
Gmail accounts that you want
to test the app with.
So apart from those accounts
apart from being able to
purchase from your unpublished
app, what's going to happen
when you try to publish with any
of those accounts is that
you're going to see a screen
just like this.
So do you notice any difference
from the screen
that we saw before?
It's exactly the same one,
except there's a warning
saying, this is a test purchase
and you won't
actually be charged.
But everything else is going
to work exactly in the same
way as a real purchase would.
So this means that you can test
your In-App purchase in
an environment that is pretty
much identical to the real
life production system.
But you won't actually
be charged.
Of course, if you want to see
the In-App Billing Version 3
code in practice, we have a
sample called Trivial Drive.
So it's an exciting driving
game that I wrote.
So you get burn fuel and
then buy more fuel.
It's kind of like the
experience of having
a car in real life.
And it's available through
the SDK manager.
And it's also available through
the Google code site.
I recommend that you get the
code directly from Google code
site because it's more
up-to-date there.
And pretty soon, we're going
to launch an update to that
app that's going to include
self-driving cars.
So summarizing, we talked about
the most challenging
points of In-App Billing V2.
We talked about how In-App
Billing V3 was designed to
address those points and make
things much easier for
developers.
We talked about subscriptions.
We talked about new API
features, such as consumption.
We talked about the new product
details API feature.
Then we talked about the server
API and gave some
pointers on security
best practices.
And we also presented IAB
sandbox, which makes it much
easier to test your apps
in a real environment.
So the reason we are improving
the API constantly and adding
these new features is we are
always striving to improve the
developer experience because we
know that if we give you a
good experience as a developer,
you can focus on
what makes your apps great.
So you can make a better
experience for your users,
which is everybody's
final goal.
So I hope that the tips
that I gave you are
useful in that respect.
And I thank you very much for
coming to this session.
If you have any feedback, there
is the rate this session
poster over there.
On previous I/Os, I know that we
had real life tomatoes you
could throw on stage.
But that was pretty messy.
So if you want to give your
feedback, just scan that QR
code over there or use
the Google I/O app
to give your feedback.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]